Hello, everyone. Welcome to a new episode of the
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by Doctor Jim Valcalilli. He's a
theoretical physicist who holds the position of Distinguished Professor
Emeritus at the University. Of Surrey in the UK
and today we're going to talk about his new
book on time, the physics that makes the universe
tick. So Dr. Alkhalili, welcome to the show. It's
an honor to everyone.
Hello, thank you very much for having me.
OK, great. So I imagine that the understanding of
time that a physicist has is very different from
how just a regular person understands time and also
different from how we understand time or how we
experience time psychologically, right? So according to physics, what
is time?
Uh, OK. Well, of course, physicists and philosophers have
been worrying about the meaning of time for thousands
of years and, and as, as have many people.
The, the thing about time is it's, it's one
of those concepts which everybody has an opinion on.
Everyone knows, will, will say they know something about
what it means. But you're right, psychological time. The
way we experience it is not the same as
the way time appears in, in, in physics, but
even in physics, we can't agree on, on the
meaning of time because different areas of physics have
different definitions of what time is. So it's it's
still a big mess.
Yes, and we're going to get into that later
because in your book you also explore the understanding
of time that we get from or we can
get from general relativity, from quantum physics, from thermodynamics.
But, uh, particularly when physicists talk about time as
being one dimension of the space-time continuum, I mean,
for a regular person, how should we understand that?
Because of course, three dimensions of space, yeah, that's
easy for us to understand, but time as another
dimension. I mean, what the
Yeah, you, you're right. I mean, we think of
dimensions as directions, right? So, we, we know what
we mean when we say we live in three
dimensional space. There are 3 dimensions that are directions
that are at right angles to each other, you
know, I can move forwards, backwards, left, right, up,
down. Those are the 3 dimensions of space. Um.
In, in physics, even before Einstein told us about
4 dimensional space-time, we know that if we want
to define what in physics we call an event,
something that happens, we need 4 numbers to locate
it in space and time. We have 3 numbers
to locate it in space because space is 3
dimensional, but we also have to say when this
event happened. So it's a moment in time as
well. Uh, SO we know that we need 4
numbers, but that doesn't mean time is a dimension.
It just means it's another label to define when
things happen. Einstein, of course, changes this, and he's,
and he says, well, in fact, it wasn't him
who first came up with time as the 4th
dimension, it was a, uh, another physicist, Herman Minkowski.
But the idea in, in Einstein's relativity theory is
that time is not separate from space. When you
define. Things happening when you measure durations of time
or even distances in space, we have different views
depending on our perspective. Uh, AND Einstein said, you
know, you know, Newton and Galileo and all these
other great physicists before me, they were wrong if
they think that time is separate from space. It's
an absolute ticking by the the seconds, minutes, hours
independently of space. He said no, time and space
are mixed up together. And if time and space
is mixed up together, that in a sense means
time is another direction. But it's not a direction
in space that's already taken by the three dimensions.
It's a direction outside of our space in a
sense that in a way we can never imagine.
So, I understand why people find it so difficult
to concept. What do you mean time is a
dimension? Well, it's, it's mathematically, it makes sense if
you study the mathematics and study the physics. But
you can't ever imagine what time as 1/4 dimension
means. It just, it's, it's what we need to,
to, to, to, to use to, to explain reality
accurately.
Talking about directions, is it really the case that
according to physics, time moves in a particular direction,
because of course we as humans and I imagine
other animals as well, experience time as moving forward
from the from the past into the present into
the future. But is that the same understanding that
we have of the movement of time in physics?
In parts of physics, yes. In other parts, there
seems to be an issue. I mean, this is
again one of those concepts where people think, really,
are you physicists really spending all your efforts to
study something that is so obvious? Of course, the
future comes after the past, of course, the past
comes before the future. So this idea is that
time has a directionality, we call it the arrow
of time. And it points from the past to
the future. What could be more obvious than that?
How could it point from the future to the
past? You know, time doesn't go backwards, it only
goes forwards in our experience. The problem in physics
is that, Apart from one area, you mentioned this
at the start, we maybe we'll talk about it
uh uh a little more uh in a minute,
uh, this area of thermodynamics, where sure, it suggests
that time really does have a direction exactly as
we perceive it psychologically. But in other areas of
physics, like Einstein's theory of relativity, like quantum mechanics,
even like Newton's equations of motion that we learned
at school, all of them seem to work. If
you change the direction of time, they say it
works in one direction, but it also works in
another. We say they are symmetric in time. So,
what is going on? If these fundamental important equations
and laws of physics are symmetric in time, and
yet we only see time going in one direction,
how does this, what we call irreversibility of time,
the arrow of time, come from. Fundamental laws and
equations that are symmetric in time. So this has
been a big puzzle and it's one that I
tackle in my book and one that I argue
I've, I, I think I know the answer to.
OK, we'll get more into that when we tackle
thermodynamics then, but in my previous question, I mentioned
the present, but does the present really exist? I
mean, is it that at any moment in time
we can really point at a present?
Well, we can psychologically because, you know, we can
only ever experience the present, uh, you know, the
future has yet to be, the past has happened
and it's gone. We are only, you know, there's
this, uh, certainly in English when we talk about
these, uh, there are phrases like live in the
moment, uh, you know, enjoy the present moment. We
can only ever live in, in, in the present
moment. So for us psychologically, the present is the
only point in time that is real. And yet,
uh um in, in, in, in physics, particularly in
relativity theory, you know, there is nothing special about
the present moment. All times coexist. All times are
equally real. Uh, AND in fact, many have argued
that this, this way of thinking means all of
time is just an illusion. If the future hasn't
happened yet, it doesn't exist. If the past is
gone, it no longer exists. And the present moment
is just the dividing line between the past and
the future. It's the edge of the shadow between
light and dark. So, in and of itself, the
present moment has no real existence. So if the
future doesn't exist, the past doesn't exists, and the
present doesn't exist, no time exists, all time is
an illusion. And there have been many philosophers over
thousands, thousands of years going back to the ancient
Greeks who've argued that time is an illusion. Of
course, the opposite view is Einstein's picture, what's called
the eternalist picture of time. That if time is
a dimension, if it's an axis, then all times
are equally real, just as all points in space
are equally real. You know, I am here, uh,
uh, in, in, in the UK talking to you.
My, the position I'm in is real, but I
know your position is also real. Uh I can
go to other places and come back again. In
Einstein's relativity, all times are equally real, not just
the present moment. So there's these two extremes, no
time exists, time is an illusion, and all times
exist, all times are real. Is the truth somewhere
in between or is one of them correct? We're
still arguing about it.
Uh, SO going back for a second to relativity,
is time relative, and if so, what does that
mean for time to be relative?
What it means is that we can't all agree
on when things happen or how long something takes.
So, um, there is no, uh, moment in time
that I will call now that everyone else will
agree with because this idea that, you know, time
is relative, because time is mixed up with space
in this four dimensional space-time. There is no absolute
time. There's no clock that ticks at the same
rate, everyone, uh, for everyone in the universe. Um,
IF I measure something that lasts for 5 seconds,
you could be flowing, moving past me at close
to the speed of light relative to me. Even
even speed is relative because you could say you're
not moving, I'm moving past you at close to
the speed of light in the opposite direction. But
what I would measure as a time interval between
two events of 5 seconds, you may see it
as 3 seconds or 10 seconds or 15 seconds,
so we can't agree on how long things last.
We see each other's clocks running at different rates.
This is what we mean by time is relative.
There is no. Single universal clock that measures time
constantly everywhere, it depends on your perspective.
And it depends also on the speed you're moving,
right.
Relative to somebody else. So, so if you're, you're
moving, you look at your clock, your clock seems
to be ticking by normally, but someone standing somewhere
else watching you go past, they will see your
clocks moving more slowly. For you, motion is relative,
you see them moving and you could see their
clocks moving slowly, so you can't agree on how
fast time is going by between you.
Yeah, that's really fascinating. Uh, BUT if time is
part of this four dimensional space-time continuum, can it
also be affected by gravity, and if so, in
what ways?
Yes, this is the other way that time uh
can be squeezed and stretched. Einstein had two theories
of relativity. His first theory, special relativity, this is
the famous one that we, you know, that gives
us E equals MC2. That's the theory that says
time is the 4th dimension, that time slows down
when you travel close to the speed of light
and so on. But 10 years after his theory
of special relativity, special relativity, Einstein published in 1905.
10 years later in 1915, he completed what we
now call his general theory of relativity. So that
is special theory, more general, made broader, and it
includes gravity in, in the description of, of the
universe. So in general relativity, Einstein says, You know,
when Newton teaches you, you know, where you still
learn at school that gravity is this force, this
invisible, uh, elastic band that pulls masses together and
attractive force. It's not really a force at all.
Einstein says, no, gravity is the shape of four-dimensional
space-time. Space-time can be curved by gravity. So, the
theory, the mathematics says space-time is curved. But for
us, what does it mean? How do we measure
it? Because for us, space and time are different
things, right? So we can do experiments to measure
distances in space, we can do experiments using clocks
to measure time. And what we find is that
gravity causes time to slow down. And this is
not just a theory, this is in fact very
well known and we can even make use of
it technologically. The stronger gravity is, the slower time
will run. When you're sitting in a gravitational field,
you don't feel any different. You don't feel like,
oh, time is going so slowly. Oh, this is
because I'm in a gravitational field. Everything is normal
for you. But outside of that gravitational field, time
will be running more quickly. So this idea of
time slowing down is a real effect. Now, in
science fiction, it's been used a lot. The the
most wonderful example I talk about this in the
book is in the film Interstellar. Uh, Matthew McConaughey
and his crew, uh, uh, in, in they, they
fly off to orbit around this, uh, black hole,
and, and, and for them, because the gravity of
the black hole is so strong, time is running
slower, and Matthew McConaughey's character knows that his young
daughter back on Earth is waiting for him, but
he knows every hour he spends in orbit around
the black hole, 7 years are passing on Earth
because his time is so slow. So he doesn't
age, but of course, when he goes back to
Earth, his young daughter's now an old lady because
time has gone faster. It's, it's science fiction, but
that is exactly what would happen if we could
go and, and, and get close to a black
hole with its strong gravity. We see that this
has a much smaller effect, but more important here
on Earth because it uh is part of GPS
systems. So whenever anybody uses Google Maps, They are
also having to acknowledge that Einstein was right about
gravity slowing time down because the satellites in orbit,
the global positioning satellites that send radio messages to
your phone to tell you where you are, they
are further away from the Earth's center, so they
feel slightly weaker gravity. And so their time can
run a bit faster than the the time at
sea level, which is closer to the Earth's center
where gravity is stronger. And scientists and engineers have
to account for this. They have to slow the
clocks, the atomic clocks, very accurate clocks, uh, that
measure time on the satellites, so that they are
running at the same speed as clocks on Earth.
If we didn't believe time slows down due to
gravity. Google Maps, GPS, satnav in your car would
not work. Or it'd it'd be very, very inaccurate
and very quickly would become completely uh useless. So,
time really does slow down in gravity.
So let's say that, and also because you mentioned
the movie Interstellar and the black hole, let's imagine
that someone, a poor soul out there, is falling
into a black hole from the standpoint of someone
watching that happening. From outside that gravitational, the gravitational
influence of the black hole, would that seem like
uh the person was falling for eternity or or
not? Yeah, yes, the, the closer they get to
the black hole's event horizon, the slower their time
will be running as perceived by someone watching them
from far away. So, uh, uh, to the point
where they get to the event horizon. And they
will freeze in the sense that it looks like
time is not running at all. Of course, we
say this because that that this is technically what
someone would see, but in reality, um, Because what
you're seeing is light coming from the falling person
and light, the frequency of light is a, is,
is depends on how fast time is running. So
as time slows down, the frequency of the light
is going down, which means the color of the
light is changing. So, in fact, before you get
to the event horizon of the black hole, the
light that's coming from your body into my eyes
for me to see you goes beyond the visible.
So you would in any case, disappear from view.
But in reality, what's happening to the person falling,
well, they don't stop at the event horizon, they
accelerate and they go straight through the event horizon,
inevitably inside to to inside the black hole, uh,
never to, to reappear again. Uh, SO it's a,
it's a matter of Who is looking at what,
uh, according to what clocks, the clocks that they
have next to them, which is measuring their time,
uh, it, it's, it's a very confusing, uh, picture,
but actually, the physics is very well understood now,
even though unlike Matthew McConaughey, we have not actually
ourselves ever visited anywhere near a black hole yet.
But of course this is not exactly about time,
but just out of curiosity, do we have a
good understanding of, uh, I mean, physically and biologically,
what a person who would be falling into a
black hole would experience? I mean, is it that
their body would just progressively disintegrate or what would
happen
exactly? Well, it, it sort of depends on what
sort, what type of black hole we're, you're falling
into. Um, A supermassive black hole like the one
in the film Interstellar is so big that the,
the, uh, gravitational pull changes slowly, gently. So as
you fall in beyond the event horizon, you won't
know that you've gone beyond the event horizon. You
wouldn't feel any difference. Uh, YOU just feel this
sense of, of, of falling of freefall. Um, YOU
would know, of course, if you try to come
out again. If you, if you're in a rocket
and you say, oh, no, no, no, I've had
enough, I want to go home now. Forget it
if you've gone past the event horizon, you're on
a one-way trip to the, to the center of
the black hole. But, uh, another type of black
hole is what's called a stellar black hole, which,
uh, is formed from a collapsing star. Those are
much smaller. Those black holes, you know, could be
just a few kilometers, uh uh in, in diameter
as seen from outside. Uh, AND there, gravity changes
very quickly. The, the, the strength of gravity, what's
called the gravitational potential, changes very quickly as you
get closer and closer to, to, to the black
hole. And so if you're falling, for example, With
your feet first, your feet pointing towards the black
hole and your head pointing away, your feet will
feel a stronger gravitational pull than your head. So
your feet will be stretching, pulling, and making you
longer. Uh, SO this is such a, an, a
terrible, uh, uh, experience to have. It's been given
the technical name in physics, spaghettification. Spaghettification means you
become like spaghetti, you get pulled and stretched. So
I always say, you know, falling into a black
hole. If you're going to fall into a black
hole, find a big one, find and you know,
a supermassive black hole at the center of a
galaxy, so at least you have the opportunity as
you're falling into the black hole to maybe, you
know, take some selfies and, and, and enjoy the
ride. Uh, YOU, you're, you're gonna most likely get
crushed to zero size anyway when you hit the
singularity, but you might as well enjoy the ride
down. If you're falling into a stellar black hole.
Yeah, you're going to be ripped apart long before
you, you get inside it.
But, but I mean, would the person be able
to send the selfies back home? Would that information
be able to escape the black hole or, or
not?
Not, not once you've gone past the event horizon.
In fact, even before the event horizon, that information
will take a very long time to get out
because it's climbing out of the gravitational hole, uh,
and it's, it's wavelength has been stretched. But in
principle, yes, if you manage to send the signal
just before you pass the event horizon, the point
of no return, then, you know, you can say
your goodbyes and you can send your photos and
people receive them. Don't send any selfies after you've
gone beyond the event horizon. It's a, it's a
waste of time.
Uh, OK, so, uh, and of course we as
humans have ways of, and over time, over our
history, we've been developing different ways of timekeeping and
of measuring time, keeping track of time. Do those
ways that we have even the most technologically advanced
ways have anything to do with how time works
according to physics?
Well, we certainly do need accurate timekeepers to measure
all sorts of phenomena and mechanisms in physics. Um,
AFTER all, time gives us a measure of change.
And in physics, most of our equations of physics
are really ways of Finding out how something changes
from one state to another, how uh a particle
moves from one place to another, how a system
evolves in time. Uh, AND so we need to
measure that time. That time is what's called coordinate
time, you know, if a system is doing something,
by system, I mean anything, you know, a particle,
a box of gas, you know, a, a planet.
If it's in a particular state at some moment
in time. Then our dynamical equations of physics will
allow us to compute what it will be doing
at some point in the future or what it
was doing at some point in the past. In
order to check these uh equations, these theories, we
need to do experiments. And to do experiments, we
need accurate timekeepers. And the more accurate the timekeeper
is, the more precise our theory can be checked.
So, so yes, in physics, we do need clocks,
and we do need clocks as accurate as possible,
especially if we're measuring very, very fast. Changes, you
know, chemical reactions that happen very fast or, or,
or, or changes that are happening at a tiny,
you know, a short duration of time, you know,
fractions and fractions of a second, uh, then we
need, Accurate, you know, to my, my, my, my
big clock on the wall in my kitchen is
not going to be able to measure how fast
a proton is moving inside an atomic nucleus, for
example, so we need lots of different clocks of
increasing accuracy to measure change in the universe.
And what is the shortest time scale that it
would be possible for us to measure? So we
have seconds, milliseconds, nanoseconds. Is something even shorter than
that? Possible for us to measure.
Yes, absolutely, um, uh, a lot of, uh, uh,
modern, uh, timekeepers use things like, um, lasers, so
laser pulses of short durations. Um, uh, THERE are
all sorts of clever tricks that can be done
to measure intervals of time far shorter even than
a nanosecond. A nanosecond is 1 billionth of a
second. At the moment, I think the shortest time
measured is of the order of a few, I
think it's a few what's called zeptoseconds. A zeptosecond
is is a trillionth of a trillionth of a
2nd, 0.000, so 23 zeros, then a 1. That's
such, such a tiny interval of time. It's not
the shortest time that we know of in nature.
There are things that happen much quicker than that,
but we're not able to measure them. So things
like certain particles have very short lifetimes. They only
exist for a tiny fraction, much less even than
a zeptosecond. Uh, WE only know they exist because
we're not. Measuring them, we're measuring what they er
change into, what they decay into. Uh, LIKE, you
know, when we say we've discovered the Higgs boson,
uh, the Large Hadron Collider, no physicists actually saw
the Higgs boson particle. No, they saw the particles
that it became after it existed for this tiny
fraction of, of a second. So in nature, things
can happen very, very quickly, certainly down at the
subatomic scale. Uh, BUT our clocks are getting. More
and more accurate and able to measure shorter and
shorter intervals of time, and when you talk about
trillionth of a trillionth of a second, you know,
that's I, I, I give examples in the book
how to compare what, what is a 1 trillion
trillions a second compared with a second or uh
is as you know, how does it compare with
a second compared with the age of the entire
universe and you realize these are just your brain
explodes when you try and, and imagine how short
a time we're talking about.
But theoretically, would there be a limit to the
shortest possible time scale that exists, or could it
be that time is theoretically infinitely divisible?
We don't know is the honest answer. Um, THERE
are current ideas and theories, in particular, uh, uh,
theories of what's called quantum gravity, uh, which are
theories that try to combine quantum mechanics, the theory,
uh, of the very small, with Einstein's general theory
of relativity. Uh, SO, a quantum version of gravity.
Some Uh, ideas in quantum gravity suggest that yes,
time ultimately, when you get small enough, it becomes
discrete, it becomes lumpy. Uh, WE reach what's called
the Planck scale, uh, and the Planck time is
therefore then the smallest interval of time that is
meaningful. Anything less than the Planck scale and time
just doesn't have a meaning anymore. Um. A lot
of physicists favor the idea that there should be
a smallest interval of time, just as there should
be a smallest, uh, length distance, the, the, the
Planck length. Um, BUT then, you know, there are
other theories that suggest that time may just continue,
as you say, be continuous all the way and,
and isn't, isn't discrete, it isn't quantized. Um, WE'VE
yet to find the correct theory of gravity. Uh,
OF quantum gravity, so we've yet to know the
answer to whether time itself is, is, uh, discrete
or not.
So earlier I asked you about the past, the
present, the future, the directionality of time. Does time
have a beginning and an end?
Another wonderful question that doesn't have a definite answer.
If you only apply Einstein's general theory of relativity,
then you would say that the Big Bang was
the origin of everything, the origin of the universe.
The Big Bang didn't happen at a moment in
time, just as it didn't happen at a point
in space. It happened everywhere in space. And it
marked the beginning of time. It's, it was, is
when space-time itself, uh, uh, uh uh was born.
So the, the, the usual, uh, um, analogy that
people use that I always like to use is
when people say, well, the Big Bang happened. You
say it's the beginning of time, but what caused
the Big Bang? There must have been a time
before for there to be a cause. There cannot
be a first cause, and, you know, philosophers have
argued about this for, for, for, for millennia. But
the analogy is, you know, if I say to
you, walk to the South Pole and keep walking,
and when you reach the South Pole, keep heading
south. Of course, you can't because once you're at
the South Pole, any step you take in any
direction will take you back north again. Uh, AND
so there is no point further south than the
South Pole. Therefore, there is no moment in time
before the Big Bang, before the moment that time
actually existed. That there's no time before the Big
Bangs. There's no point in saying what happened before
because there was no time for the word before
to exist in. But, but there's the big but
here, which makes this whole subject so fascinating. Einstein's
general theory of relativity, which says the Big Bang
is the birth of time, may not be the
last word on the subject. It may be that
the Big Bang was simply the moment that our
universe was, was created, our bubble within some, some
multiverse. Maybe time is eternal, maybe time goes all
the way back to infinity and at some moment
within the multiverse, our universe popped into existence. So
it did happen at a moment in time. There
are other ideas which suggest the Big Bang. Uh,
MIGHT have been the birth of our universe, but
the universe cycles, it, it, it, it is born,
it expands, it recollapses, it's born again. So this
cyclic picture of time repeating, not repeating itself because
the, the next generation universe will be very different
presumably to ours, certainly in terms of what happens
in it. Um. So we don't know whether time
had a beginning. When it comes to whether time
has, will have an end, again, we don't know
for sure. We talk about time. If you fall
into a black hole, then as you fall towards
the center, what what's called the singularity of the
black hole, that point marks the end of space
and time. It's the edge of space and time,
just like the Big Bang is the singularity for
the beginning of the universe, which marks the beginning
of time. So the interior of a black hole
could be the end of time, but that doesn't
mean that's the fate of our universe that is
going to like it'll be like falling into a
black hole. The Current's idea is that our universe
will most likely continue to expand forever. How it
expands the nature of that expansion because we're still
trying to understand uh what's called dark energy, which
is this mysterious thing that's making the universe expand
ever more quickly. We don't understand the nature of
dark energy, so we don't know exactly how the
universe will expand, what the fate will be. But
in any case, that in that scenario, time will
continue forever. It maybe nothing happens and the universe
just dies, the heat, uh, heat death and it
just, it keeps on expanding, getting colder and colder.
Everything is spread out and it reaches what's called
thermal equilibrium. Nothing changes. But in my view, time
still exists, even though there's no measure of change
to. Tell us that time still exists. It's still
passing by, it's still pointing to the future, from
an earlier moment all the way back to the
Big Bang. So, If I were Uh, to make
a guess, I would say the most likely thing
for me is that time did have a beginning,
but it won't have an end. Uh, BUT, you
know, I could very well be wrong. Yeah, and
I'm sure there would be people who would say,
yes, Jim, you are wrong. Well, uh,
let's also see if we are still here to
really experience whether time has an end or not.
Well,
well, well, OK, so that that is the big
problem. We're not going to be around to be
able to check that idea, so I can say
anything, prove me wrong.
But, but when it comes to the origins of
our universe, and I mean if that also marks
the origins of time, uh, sometimes I hear physicists
and philosophers of science debate whether the universe came
from something or came from nothing. I mean, at
this, at this moment. In time, er, is there
enough evidence to say whether one of those hypotheses
is more supportive than the other?
Well, it depends what we mean by by saying
it comes from something, you know, we can, we
can think of time as coming from. Uh, A,
a quantum fluctuation, uh, uh, some, somehow down in
the quantum realm, time itself. Doesn't exist. Time is
emergent, uh, uh, uh, an emergent property, it's not
a fundamental concept of reality. Um, OUR universe could
have emerged from a quantum fluctuation. People say, you
know, where does the energy of, you know, all
the, the stuff of the universe come from? Well,
you, you, you can argue that, uh, the positive
energy of that created all the matter. Uh, IS
balanced by the negative gravitational, uh, uh, energy, and,
and there are technical, um, explanations for this, but
in terms of, um, Whether our universe had a
cause, you know, what caused the universe? Could it
have just appeared spontaneously? Out, out of, out of
nothing. Um, IN a sense, this is more of
a philosophical question or metaphysical question because we are
reaching the point where physicists start to get nervous
about, about trying to come up with explanations. Um,
PHYSICS is a is an empirical, uh, uh, uh
field. It's an experimental field. You, you have a
theory or hypothesis, you have to test it to
see if it's right or not. We have theories
at the moment, which many would argue are not
real science because they can't be tested, you know,
theories of quantum gravity, for example, like string theory.
Uh, BUT I, but I, they are real scientific
theories because it's not that we can't experimentally test
them, it's just that we don't currently have the
means to do it, you know, you, you can't
build an accelerator big enough to, to, to probe
such a small dimensions of space and time. Um.
But when it comes to, well, did the universe
have a a first cause. Or was there an
earlier generation universe before ours? Some physicists argue so
that, uh, Roger Penrose, a Nobel Prize winner, um,
colleague of Stephen Hawking's, uh, Roger Penrose is a,
is a, is a genius, mathematical physicist. He's, he's,
uh, he's 95 now. I mean, I know this
because he's the same age as my father, so
I'm always, you know, thinking about him when his
birthday comes by. I mean, he's still active. Uh,
HE has this idea of what's called the, um,
Uh, uh, a cyclic universe that repeats itself, you
know, it, it, the Big Bang expands and then
it becomes uh, uh, the Big Bang for another
universe. Um, SO he would argue that there wasn't
a first cause, there was an earlier generation universe,
a, a previous epoch. Um, AND he would argue
actually there may be ways of of testing that
idea, uh, somehow that the signature or the imprint
or evidence of an earlier universe might still exist
out in, in our universe if we could measure
certain properties of space, uh, uh, very, very carefully.
Um, SO, yeah, uh, what did our universe have
a cause, or did it come from nothing? Uh,
I, for me, this is still a philosophical, metaphysical
question, uh, uh, and not really yet something that
physicists can address seriously.
Mhm. Uh, IN regards to some other metaphysical questions
that many times people, uh, tie in with, uh,
physics, does the way that physics understand time. Uh,
UNDERSTANDS time have any bearing on questions surrounding determinism
and free will. I mean, is there any link
there?
Oh, absolutely, a very strong link, uh, um, I,
I have, I devote a chapter in the book
to, to this idea, um. The great French mathematician,
uh, uh, Laplace, uh, came up with uh um
this thought experiment, which we now call Laplace's demon.
He said, if you could imagine a, a super
intelligent being that could know the positions and, and
the movements of every particle in the universe very
precisely. Then they, in principle should be able to
compute what will happen to those particles uh uh
in the future, how they will collide, how they
will interact, and therefore this super being would be
able to predict, who would be able to see
the future, um. Of course, I, and I, as
I explained in the book, there are many reasons
why this is wrong and, and it would never
be able to do that. But that doesn't mean
that we don't live in what's called a deterministic
universe. A determinism simply means that the future is,
is set. It's not that the future is existing
waiting for us, but what will be will be.
The fate of the universe is already. Determined in
advance. The interesting thing here, and this is how
it links with free will, is that we can
never predict that future. You can't see the future
of the universe of space-time unless you could be
outside of the universe, what's called the God's eye
view, to see the universe from outside. From within
the universe, it's impossible to predict the future. Even
if when the future happens, you say, ah, of
course this was always going to happen, you know,
uh, I had no control to to to to
make it otherwise. But while we're living only in
the present moment. Because we can't predict or see
the future. So when people say, you know, I,
I can see the future, I predict this, no,
you can't. You're a charlatan. Um, BECAUSE we can't
predict the future, even in principle, I mean, we
can make some. Predictions a little bit into the
future, I can say that, for example, tomorrow I'll
be a day older. The sun will shine, will
rise. Um, uh, I can predict that even though
if I toss one coin, I don't know if
it's going to be heads or tails, but I
can predict if I toss 1000 coins, half of
them will be heads, half will be tails. Our
computer models of the climate are predicting that the
the Earth's climate is changing due to uh humanity's
actions. So those are predictions we can make based
on what we understand now. But predicting what will
happen next becomes more and more difficult, the more
complex the system is that we're trying to describe
and the further in in the future we're trying
to describe it. For that reason, I always argue
that even though we may live in a deterministic
universe, which we may not, by the way. But
even if we do live in a deterministic universe,
because we can't predict that future for all intents
and purposes, we have free will, we have free
agency because it, it may be an illusion if
viewed from outside the universe, but from within the
universe, our free will is real, you know, we
can choose what we want to do, even if
afterwards we say, ah, but I didn't really have
a choice, this was always going to happen. At
the time, we are making free choices. This is
what's called compatibleism. And, uh, and, and, and many
philosophers don't like it. They say, oh, you want
determinism, the future's fixed, but you also want free
will. No, no, that's cheating. Yeah, tough luck. I,
I, I, I think it's a, a, a valid
and a reasonable view.
Uh, BUT, uh, that question surrounding determinism and free
will, does it also apply? At a psychological level,
I mean, what I mean is our understanding of
how time works from a physics perspective, apart from
whether apart from allowing us to answer or potentially
answer whether the universe itself is deterministic or not,
can it also have any bearing on whether psychologically
we have free will or not?
I think it's certainly uh the fact that we
can't predict the future. Uh, uh, uh, MEANS we,
I mean, I certainly can't predict what you will
do next. I'm, I, I may be, you know,
basing it on, you know, our brief conversation so
far for this podcast, and I, I make a
prediction you're going to ask me another question about
the nature of time. Um, BUT we can't read
someone's mind, we can't predict what they're doing, even
though our brains. You know, our psychology is based
on our consciousness. Our consciousness is really the software
of the brain. It's, it's the firing and connections
of, of neurons in, in tens of billions of
neurons in the brain. Um, SO there's nothing magical
about, Uh, consciousness and, and, and therefore our behavior,
and yet it's far too complex for us ever
to predict what someone will do for, for, for,
for in for certainty, uh, in, in the next
moment or or or or or beyond it because
it's too, too complex, too many parameters to, to,
to. Keep hold of. So, not predicting the future
also means not being able to predict what someone
else would do, and indeed what not to predict
what we ourselves may may do given certain circumstances,
because we are complex systems embedded within a complex
world. Uh, AND so I think Having determinism doesn't
rule out. Acting freely and therefore, having moral and
and ethical responsibilities. You know, you can't say, well,
you know, there's no such thing as free will,
the universe is deterministic. So it wasn't my fault
that I committed this crime, you know, it was,
it was, this is just, this is just the
laws of physics, you know, making, no, we still
have moral and free uh uh will to behave
in a certain way, and it doesn't matter. That
in the future, we might look back and say
we couldn't have behaved otherwise at at the time,
psychologically. The future is open to us.
So over the course of our conversation we've been
talking about the understanding we have of how time
works from the perspective of quantum mechanics and general
relativity. Could you tell us more about the thermodynamics?
I mean, what understanding of time we can get
from that framework, and then do you think it's,
it would be possible to reconcile all of these
three different frameworks?
This is the area of my book that I
spent the longest thinking about and and and and
writing about because it's, it's the most fascinating. Thermodynamics
goes back to the 19th century. It began as
a, as the field of study of the nature
of energy and heat and work, uh, and, and
it linked in the development of, of, of engines
in the industrial age. Um, BY the second half
of the 19th century, uh, and, and a related
field also was developed called statistical mechanics. So, essentially,
thermodynamics and statistical mechanics are about the properties of
matter. In bulk, in large quantities. So, concepts like
pressure or temperature, uh, and, and heat are ideas
in thermodynamics and statistical mechanics that emerge when you
have lots and lots of, uh, subsystems moving parts.
So, uh, a box of, of gas, you can
say it has a temperature, it has a pressure
pushing on the, on the, uh, walls of the
box. But if you look down at the level
of individual molecules, there is no such thing as
pressure. There's no such thing as temperature. It's just
the movement of of the kinetic energy of the
molecules. But what's fascinating when it comes to the
nature of time is that in thermodynamics and statistical
mechanics, um, time does seem to have a direction,
a directionality. It's irreversible, um. In its simplest form,
it's what I call, I'm not the only one,
but what physicists might call statistical inevitability. That if
you have a box of gas and all the
molecules of gas are pushed into one corner, then
over time, those molecules will spread out to fill
the whole box. So, there's a direction to time
from the molecules being uh all clumped together to
the molecules being spread out evenly in in equilibrium.
That directionality of time, uh, is, is encompassed in
what we call the second law of thermodynamics. It's
always amusing that it's a very, very important law
in physics, but it's still #2 in laws of
thermodynamics. It's not the first law, it's only the
2nd law. Um, BUT it's, it's very, uh, interesting
that the 2nd law of thermodynamics seems to apply
so widely to so many phenomena. Uh, IT'S really
a statement about the increase of what's called entropy.
Uh, uh, AND entropy is a, is a concept
that has many different meanings and definitions depending on,
on, on what area of physics or what, what
the thing is that you want to explain. One
simple example of entropy increasing is molecules of gas
spreading out to equilibrium. Another favorite example of mine
is a pack of playing cards. Uh, THE pack
of cards, when you get them new from the
box, they're all arranged hearts, diamonds, spades, and clubs,
all, you know, uh, 23456, all the way jack,
queen, king, ace, organized in, in suits and in
ascending order. When you shuffle the deck of cards,
they become more disordered. So one of the most
common ways of of defining entropy and therefore the
second law of thermodynamics, which says entropy always increases,
is to say it's disorder that increases. Shuffling a
deck of cards will make it more disordered. It
won't make it more ordered. Things run down, things
become messier. Um, SO this is, this is the
directionality of time in, in, in thermodynamics, the entropy
always, uh, increases. But this is in thermodynamics and
of course, as we mentioned earlier, in other areas
of physics like relativity theory, like quantum mechanics, even
like Newton's mechanics, there isn't this directionality to time.
There seems to, time seems to be able to
work equally well in both directions. So, this, this
has been a long standing problem in physics. How
does the irreversibility, the arrow of time, which is
so obvious to us in everyday life and so
obvious from the Second law of thermodynamics. Yet doesn't
seem to exist in the other areas of physics.
How do we get one from the other? And
this is a one of the big puzzles that
I, I tackle, uh, later on in my book.
Uh, BUT do you think it would be theoretically
possible to reconcile all of these different frameworks?
I think it's it's possible to reconcile how time.
Uh, uh, HAS a directionality in thermodynamics, but not
in other areas of physics. I, I think that
is, is perfectly possible. I mean, certainly, uh, uh,
what we would argue is that, Uh, in an
isolated system like a box of gas, um. The,
the, the system always wants to move towards equilibrium
from being not in equilibrium like all the all
the particles or the molecules in one corner of
the box to being spread out. Um, THE dynamical
equations, if you're, if you look at individual molecules
and how they move, what they would say is
if you could run the movie backwards. You should
equally well see. Uh, uh, ENTROPY increasing into the
past. So entropy is increasing into the future because
the molecules are spreading out. But the equations say
you can also run entropy backwards and, and it
will increase the time backwards and entropy will increase.
This is the symmetry of time. I argue that
you can't do that because the box of gas
is not an isolated system. Well, it it could
be an isolated system while those molecules are spreading
out, but you had to intervene and push the
molecules in the corner from outside to get that
going. You had to push the system away from
equilibrium, and that's because the system is not isolated.
So, for me, this idea that time is symmetric
in the dynamical equations of physics is an idealization.
It only applies in isolated systems. And there's no
such thing as a truly isolated system in our
universe. Everything is interacting with everything else and therefore
time is always flowing in one direction. The only
system that is truly isolated, that doesn't have an
outside is the whole universe. And that's the only
place we have to worry about reconciling. The arrow
of time from thermodynamics with this time symmetric equations
of physics. And even there, physicists and cosmologists have
come up with an answer. They say this. They
say, if today, uh, entropy of the universe is
some value, there's a, the universe has a certain
level of order or disorder. Tomorrow and next week,
it will be more disordered. Stars will be shining
more and spreading out their energy just like the
molecules of gas are spreading in the box. So
tomorrow entropy will be higher, so there's an arrow
of time pointing from today through to the future,
but. If the universe is truly isolated and and
subject to the symmetric equations of physics, then yesterday
and last week, entropy should be much higher than
today in violation of the Second Law of thermodynamics.
You can't have entropy increasing to the future from
today, but you can pass from today. But is
today a special moment? OK, maybe not today, maybe
last week or maybe a month ago. Then all
moments from a month ago to the future, entropy's
increasing. Great, we've solved the problem of last week
being higher entropy than today. But what about 2
months ago? I, so the only way to solve
this is, hey, let's move that special moment all
the way back to the Big Bang. And then
every moment after the Big Bang, entropy's increasing. But
what about before the Big Bang? Ah, there's no
before the Big Bang, so we don't have to
worry about that problem. Therefore, we've solved it. This
is what's called the past hypothesis. It's a crazy
idea. It seems like cheating, but it works. But
it's only needed for the whole universe. Within the
universe, there is an arrow of time.
So I have two more questions, and of course,
and of course the next one, I mean I
really have to ask it because otherwise I would
be publicly executed by my audience because it's
I even know what you're going to ask me,
but go ahead yeah.
OK, so about uh time travel. Uh YEAH, so,
of course, er there's, um, I er er there's
possibly different ways that we can tackle this question
in, in the popular understanding, I mean maybe if
people would be thinking about time traveling as they
see in some movies or books that like, I
don't know, in movies like. Uh, Donnie Darko, and
these people are more into independent slash cult movies,
movies like Prime and things like that, and then
of course, uh, they can get into, uh, time
paradoxes. I don't know, let's say, oh, I, I
want to, I want to jump into a time
machine and go back in time to kill Hitler
to prevent World War II, but maybe then. The
consequence of that is that my parents won't meet
and I won't be there in the future. So
if I'm not there in the future, how am
I back here in the past, you know, those
kinds of those kinds of, those kinds of funny
things. But I mean those kinds. Of explorations that
we have in sci-fi about surrounding time traveling, are
those legitimately scientific ways of approaching it or not?
And if not, how do physicists approach it?
Yeah, the notion of time travel does seem to,
it, it doesn't have the respectability of other areas
studying the nature of time. I mean, for that
reason, my, my chapter on time travel, I, I
left to the very end of the book. I
called it a bonus chapter because I didn't want
to have it included in all the serious stuff
about entropy and thermodynamics and space-time and so on.
But you're right, you know, you have to address
this question. Well, actually, Our current best theory of
the nature of time is Einstein's general theory of
relativity. And the way we test theories is to
push them to the limit. So we are trying
to study them under extreme scenarios, which may not
be realistic, but we want to see if we
can break the theory. And one way of testing
how time uh is is defined in general relativity
is to consider what are called closed time-like curves.
Essentially ways of traveling back in time. It's not
like time running backwards. So it's so if you
travel through a time-like curve or a longer time-like
curve, it's not that you will, you will check
your, your, your, your, your watch to see the
tick, the seconds ticking backwards. You're moving forward in
time. But it's a bit like on, on a,
in, in a theme park ride on the roller
coaster, and you're looping the loop. So you, you,
you're going around, you're moving forward, but you're doubling
back and returning to, to, to your original position
in space. In this case, it'll be returning to
your position in time or even to an earlier
moment from when you, you left. You're right, it
leaves all sorts of paradoxes that we have to
solve. But the, the laws of physics themselves don't
forbid time travel. Uh, AND all the time they
don't forbid it, it gives us a way of
testing our theories. So there are very respectable, um,
scientific research papers and journals over many years studying.
The nature of time like curves uh and the
possibility of traveling to the past. They're they're not
talking about building a time machine to, you know,
to go back and visit your grandparents or to
visit your younger self, that's left to the science
fiction movies, but they do try and and deal
with these things, uh, mathematically. My view is that,
I think if we had a better theory of
time, maybe a theory of quantum gravity, which also
included some aspects of thermodynamics, of course, because we
need to include all our current ideas in physics
uh uh uh uniformly, um, then we might find
that closed time-like curves are impossible, that they are
forbidden by the laws of physics. At the moment,
they're not forbidden, right? So all the time, they're
still possible. It's a serious area of research, but
it's also a fun thing to speculate on whether
we can travel back in time. Traveling to the
future, in a sense, you can do that. Well,
you can travel to the future just by sitting
still, you know, tomorrow will come, right? Um, BUT
you can travel to the future, if you travel
close to the speed of light or if you
sit in a gravitational field to slow your time
down. That's not real time travel to the future
because real time travel to the future would expect,
The future to already exist waiting for you. Now,
what's happening here is you're just moving out of
everyone else's timeline, getting to the future before everybody
else, so it's not real time travel. Time travel
to the past would require real time travel. I,
I don't think it will be possible, but at
the moment, I can't rule it out. And there
are possibilities, ways of getting around the paradoxes, by
the way, such as, uh, in, in if we
subscribe to the many worlds interpretation of quantum mechanics
and there are multiple realities, you could go back
to the past, which will be a past in
another. Uh, uh, TIMELINE in which you don't have
to cause any paradoxes. So, who knows, possibly.
OK, so just one final question then. Among the
still unanswered questions regarding time from the standpoint of
physics, which is the one that you would love
the most to see answered? I mean, which is
the one that you would be, oh my God,
if this was answered in my lifetime, it would
be amazing.
Normally when I'm asked this question, it's, it's, it's
broader than that. What question in physics would I
like answered? You see, I, and I have a
good answer for that, uh, which, which is that
I would like to know what is the correct
interpretation of quantum mechanics. But that answering that question
would also help with trying to understand the nature
of time because in some interpretations of quantum chaos,
like uh Everett's many worlds interpretation, there are these
parallel realities within the multiverse that would suggest that
time travel is allowed, that that uh we we
may not in practice be able to move from
one timeline to another. Uh, BUT in principle, mathematically,
that allows for the possibility of time travel, even
if we're, we never technologically developed, uh, uh, build
a time machine. However, if another interpretation is true
that, for example, what's called the Bohmian mechanics or
pilot wave theory mechanics, uh, then there is only
one universe and, and the paradoxes of time travel
are real. Uh, uh, AND therefore that I would
argue would rule out time travel into the past.
Time has to continue forward. Um, FOR me, that
will be the, the biggest, uh, uh, uh, uh,
uh, question to answer. I think, um, ideas about
arrows of time and does an arrow of time
emerge from time symmetric equations or are time symmetric
equations merely idealizations in the universe that already has
an arrow. Uh, I don't know if we'll ever
have a satisfactory, definite answer to that. I certainly
Pick a side in the book. I, I, I
have a perspective on it and I argue the
case for that. And you know, I think I'm,
I, I, I'd like to think I'm right in
the way I'm thinking. I want to persuade other
physicists that I'm right. Uh, BUT I'm, I'm not
sure there will be a big discovery in physics
that will say, Jim was right all the time.
Uh, IN any case, I was not the first
person to, to, to, to have this view. So
I wouldn't, I wouldn't take credit for it even
if there was some proof.
Uh, GREAT. So the book is again on time,
the physics that makes the universe tick, and of
course I will be leaving a link to it
in the description of the interview. And Dr. Alkhalili,
it's been a great conversation, uh, very fascinating. Talk.
So thank you so much for coming on the
show, and I've been a great admirer of yours,
so it's been an honor to everyone. Oh,
thank you, thank you very much, Ricardo. It's been,
it's been great fun. I, I, as you can
probably tell, I like talking about this stuff, so
it's been a pleasure being on the program.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inasi Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoro, and
Hal Herz Agnon, Michel Jonathan Labrarith, John Yardston, and
Samuel Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel,
Sardusran, David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezara Romain Roach, Diego
Londono Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro,
Adam Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka, Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltonin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Eddin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolatti, Gabriel Pan
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffyanny Smith,
and Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophanous, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Janaertner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov, Sean
Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special thanks
to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank, Lucas Stink,
Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas Trumbull,
Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al Nick
Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive producers,
Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie. Thank
you for all.